SAME PERSON.
SHE HAS LOST IT.
>> Laura: THAT IS THE ANKLE.
HERE NOW TO REACT AS
GOVERNOR MIKE HUCKABEE, THE
FORMER CANDIDATE AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
DID SHE CHANGE OR TO THE MODERN
DEMOCRATS TO CHANGE HER?
>> I NEARLY LOST IT WHEN YOU
SAID THAT JOE BIDEN AND
NANCY PELOSI LOOKS LIKE VISITING
ANGELS, THAT HAS TO BE THE
FUNNIEST LINE I HAVE HEARD AND
SEVERAL MONTHS.
ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC.
I DO THINK NANCY PELOSI IS
STRUGGLING TO TRY TO MAINTAIN
SOME ORDER.
SHE IS TRYING TO HURT THE GREEN
FLIES AND I USE THAT TERM
DELIBERATELY.
THIS IS A REAL TOUGH SPOT FOR
HER.
HERE IS THE THING THAT I LOVE
WHAT HE HAS DONE.
HE IS NOT ALLOWING HER TO GO OUT
THERE, CALL HIM A CRIMINAL
SAYING HE IS COMMITTING CRIMES
BY COVERING THINGS UP AND THEN
WALK OVER TO HIS HOUSE AND LOOK
HIM IN THE EYE AND PRETEND THAT
SHE WANTS TO DO SOME LEGISLATION
HE IS CALLING HER OUT.
HE IS NOT PLAYING THIS
RIDICULOUS D.C. SEMANTICS GAME
OF SANDY GENTLE LADY FROM
CALIFORNIA, THERE IS NOTHING
GENTLE ABOUT THE LADY FROM
CALIFORNIA.
>> Laura: HERE'S THE HISTORIAN
ELEVATING THE SAN FRAN GRAN NAN.
>> SHE IS THE GLUE KEEPING THE
WHOLE WASHINGTON SCENE TOGETHER.
>> Laura: WHAT IS THIS?
>> I THINK THE GLUE HAS LOST ITS
STICKY.
THERE SOMETHING GOING ON.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE NOTHING RIGHT
NOW.
THE MUELLER REPORT LEFT THEM
HANGING AND SO NOW THEY ARE A
BUNCH OF KIDS WHO ARE LOOKING
FOR EASTER EGGS ON THE
FOURTH OF JULY.
THEY JUST WON'T LET THIS GO.
IT'S MAKING THEM LOOK MORE AND
MORE RIDICULOUS.
THERE WAS IN FACT A CONSPIRACY,
A COVER-UP AND AN ATTEMPTED COUP
BUT IT WASN'T CONDUCTED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP, OR CANDIDATE
TRIAL.
IT WAS CONDUCTED BY THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
WHEN BARACK OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT
AND WHEN YOU HAD NAMES LIKE
BRENNAN AND CLAPPER AND McGAHN
WHO WERE LEADING ALL OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS.
>> Laura: THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THIS CLEARLY.
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
DECLASSIFIED AND WE WILL SEE A
LOT MORE ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF
THIS INVESTIGATION WITH GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS AND ALL OF THE
CHARACTERS, LIKE A JAMES
PATTERSON NOVEL BY THE TIME IT'S
ALL OVER.
>> THEY NEED TO BE WORRIED
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT THEY FOUND
AN BILL BARR IS A NO NONSENSE
LOG GUY, HE BELIEVES IN THE RULE
OF LAW AND HE BELIEVES IT.
HE BELIEVES IT APPLIES TO
EVERYBODY INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT, BUT THE BEST ATTEMPT
AFTER $35,000,000.500 WITNESSES
WAS THAT THEY COULDN'T FIND
ANYTHING THAT WOULD MAKE
DONALD TRUMP BE CRIMINALLY
LIABLE OR EVEN, IN ANY WAY
LIABLE AND SO NOW THEY ARE JUST
REDUCED TO HOWLING AT THE MOON
AND THAT IS WHAT THEY HAD BEEN
REDUCED TO.
FRANKLY IT'S EMBARRASSING.
>> Laura: MEANWHILE WE HAVE
REALLY IMPORTANT CRISES AT THE
BORDER, TRUMP SAID TODAY NANCY
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THE EMBASSY
AND SHE NEEDS TO LEARN WHAT THE
NEW TRADE DEAL WOULD DO FOR THE
COUNTRY.
SHE IS NOT INTERESTED.
SHE IS INTERESTED AND RESISTING
AND APPEALING TO THE AOC BASE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
YOU SEE HER STRUGGLING.
IT'S LIKE AN INTERNAL STRUGGLE
FOR RELEVANCE, MEMORY, I DON'T
KNOW.
IT'S A COMBINATION OF A LOT OF
THINGS.
I'M NOT A PSYCHOLOGIST I CAN
UNPACK IT.
GREAT TO SEE YOU AS ALWAYS.